love how this big three love it love it
what's your involvement besides being a
reporter I love that
I'm Nicole they're calling me Tommy the
Howard Cosell a big fan humbly out tears
you I'll tear you that's what they're
called you ever date a lot of people
refer to me like they'll be like oh
there's Michael Rapaport the Howard
Cosell of the big three chin when we
were downstairs and you picked me up
wasn't that guy just saying oh the
Howard Cosell the big 30 there's a
Howard Cosell the victory sometimes they
don't even know my name they'll be like
oh [ __ ] there's the Howard Cosell the
big three I'm so I'm just saying but I
love it I just love it such a [ __ ]
fan and like our vascular love it you
love and I will bust your ass 101 but
you know you're not Bieber I will [ __ ]
you up
listen I mean think about looking down a
bride goes under your house so no one
has to see her and I know we don't bring
change we're going to film it
bring [ __ ] [ __ ] we'll bring all the
times while I'm trying to do a [ __ ]
solid here no I'm trying to do the real
car do you like Conor McGregor tried to
do Paulie that [ __ ] dirtbag I'm gonna
do him like you did my man pull have you
like all your heroes all your years of
fighting all your years of training
without my Pratt gotta have a point of
view and you got to trust it and and and
it and your voice isn't just your
talking voice it's not just your [ __ ]
talking boys because when you should
talk you you you could go forward you
double back then I could talk about your
shoes all day I talked about him at the
beginning I talked about him now I could
say your shoes look like [ __ ] like it
look at how much they are you oh my god
oh my god like you shouldn't be betting
that kind of money because you're gonna
lose it all on this Connor fight and
you're gonna have a pair of [ __ ]
cowboy boots that you pay for how much
may 11 and all those things are not to
how much they're not Eve how much do you
waste on these [ __ ] up cowboy boots
with heels
who wears shoes with heels in 2007
single Aurora see the [ __ ] god damn it
round
Rod Stewart wouldn't wear these [ __ ]
[ __ ] in his prime Rod Stewart wear wear
those in the do you think of it as going
wood [ __ ] no he wouldn't wait would go
where this David Rowley would say those
are strong can fend on me go take a pic
for your girl and say hey what do you
think his boots you did oh my god
[ __ ] love them get them please
you did well there's always his plan
selector with a plane be after me
whether hey you know neither all series
but you just don't know anymore you know
I'm saying you just kind of take it as
it is it's a smart movie
it's a spectacular smart move we know if
we just play out the way we're shooting
it plays out it that way you know but
but I don't even know if I'm saying this
is not 10 years ago about 10 years at
all with a world champion isolate the
conference paralysis this is 12 Ice
Arena in the center of all the
controversy all the time you're insane
but but as a form of my career I don't
want to make my money and still win one
thing so so the photos brought if you're
home Russia's host or it wasn't my
intention I could have gone about it and
honestly if I camaraderie that's apropos
it come out of it it was really more
forward for my time time to pull it but
the other thing to I think you know as
big as the name you are in box and I
think you know you're the the most
popular MMA or boxing fighter man among
MMA fans site fully Mayweather now you
know so that that's a pro it builds it
builds kind of you know your name in
that regards and I don't you know no
matter what comes out of it I think you
know you have a personal experience with
Conor that's going to help you on the
broadcast so I think there's a few pros
there yeah yeah I mean I got anything of
it like that so I mean obviously from a
tactical standpoint I guess that I'm an
accident old guy and I'm gonna I'm gonna
be able to bring out a couple extra
knowledge on the broadcast I would not
have done um if I had not taken part in
earnest following questions of Conor
but of course you know this is this is
you know this is all social you know the
pros and cons are also flying in to you
know now he's put out a video with you
clearly see a dirty either side he
pushes the head down how often rabbit
fortunate I mean nothing that little
quip and it's funded it's edited how
many times you push it ahead down how
many times you driving point you in that
clip because you take it close for one
round and go the other on you don't see
it won the clip you're not learning a
single punch because you might have done
the other clip his landing some shots
he's stolen splats instead of turning
the pump over he's gonna live at one be
pushing my head down in that clip suit
yeah II like all you got it basically
alert the media like look at
modified inside I want to be really
dirty yeah everything has sold 36 going
wrong you have to be taught one
now everybody not attacked out of the
bed with him so he's actually shot
himself in the foot in that world filled
with it I'm sure I wasn't intending to
do that you know when should I get on
trt maybe when I'm 55 60 60 you think
chin would you do trt I don't know I
would love to see if Brian did it first
like grade you look like carrot top your
blood would be all you play I don't
wanna be that guy all you don't be like
that but maybe when I'm 60 right I don't
feel like need it right you don't my
[ __ ] what do i do you can kind of
mean action I don't think I need it
touch your sex dress it's been a while
man so I don't know oh yeah oh there but
it's my joint you know you're in in the
drought so you know we do a little kick
with trt might help you know what we do
in baseball when you're drought what's
that you slump-buster hey what's a swamp
Buster Brenda you guys know a slump but
no man life is all swamp Buster
slump-buster The Grateful type catch my
drift
boys I was always about to Grateful
types I was always about the waves a
you're staying high you know you looking
for guarana when you need a Brianna but
sometimes you get you know by Brianna I
mean 40 50 year old mom or having kids
we're just abroad hey hey hey that's a
sub buster okay yeah or you just get hey
miss kitchen a slump-buster and get a
girl for you kind of a diamond in the
rough you know she doesn't have to be 50
maybe she's know y'all hungry let's say
22 but she's a hardcore one thank you
ever and she loves her big Korean oh now
to mix it all or you get a girl who's
just who is a little bigger than most
but is it strong you know some girls can
be bigger but they're hard like they're
kind of they're they're stocky I'm very
happy with that body type I've had good
time you'll to help I've had good times
I like semester women yeah I've had good
times with a soggy sake xsprinter